this is Startalk susan minogue from
facebook asks how sure we about our map
of our galaxy in the universe in general
could our tools techniques be mapping an
illusion and that the universe is much
smaller or larger than we've calculated
your show is called space-time yeah well
you take everything we know based on
lies I mean it it could just be that
there's a giant dome that painted kind
of like The Wizard of Oz right and are
we in a super classic ated ruling show I
think that the closest thing to that is
the idea of the holographic universe
where you have this vastly distant shell
that's a hologram and that our three
demented to protect you from two highly
highly hypothetical and leaving us a
theoretical so the answer all right how
do we how do we measure this stuff with
with many scientists working
independently making measurements
independently and getting agreed-upon
results um in the case of the map of our
universe is pointing multiple different
telescopes at distant galaxies and and
you know basically calculating redshifts
and so I getting distances by different
independent methods so I would add that
we use a regular telescope that is
sensitive to visible light and that's
the extension of our retina and we see a
galaxy there now somebody else invents
an infrared telescope or microwave
telescope or a radio telescope and we
scan the sky we find the same object but
now emitting in these other bands so
this gives us confidence that the object
is real that it's actually there and
some interesting things are happening in
it and that it's not and then like as
you were saying before it erupted you
and you that you can get the distance to
this object by multiple ways they're not
standard ways you would measure
distances on earth under if you can pace
out the distance you could get a little
tape measure you can use now one of
these
like a wheel light laser laser thingy so
there multiple ways if you get the same
answer from all those ways and all those
ways are completely different from one
another you have confidence you have the
right distance to the object yeah and so
yeah so this you combine all of these
factors we think the universe is real
and it is what we measure it to be but
you can get take a deeper philosophical
point that there is no reality beyond
the measurement the measurement becomes
the reality of the universe that we
describe so to say it really is this
other thing
you're just not measuring it to be so
I'll say how will you ever know that
it's this other thing well I don't know
the question wouldn't be that it's
another thing it's just that we are
wrong now how would you know that we are
there's so so we learned in quantum
physics you learn in kloppenburg hahaha
that the reality of the world only makes
sense through the measurement right in a
sense yeah the sense so you cannot it
doesn't that mean anything to talk about
a world that is outside of a measurement
so definitely you know what that's what
Niels get not say it's just to it I
think what I think I think others I
think you know for example David Bohm
and and and and realists would would
argue I like I think the important thing
is not to confuse the the idea that the
you know we have a subjective experience
of the universe and that that subjective
experience isn't the universe it's a
different thing to the actual universe
and but nonetheless the universe remains
consistent our subjective experience of
the universe matches other people's
subjective experience we can all make
measurements that agree with each other
and that gives us confidence that there
is something objectively real out there
even if we can't say exactly what it is
and I would add to that about tie a bow
on it that I look at something and I say
okay that looks red to me well my on
drugs or not ok so that be a subjective
reality so then you devise an experiment
so an apparatus that measures
wavelengths of light and you've already
calibrated it so that this wavelength is
a red over
so now you come to this and the machine
measures red as well is the machine on
drugs you're going to let us show you
what red means yes we're going to teach
it over here what red is and then we
look at this thing that I'm looking at
and so now we both query the Machine
what color is this and the Machine gives
us the same answer so I've removed my
own brain from this experiment and I'm
getting the same answer so to limit our
subjective experience is reality but we
know the limits of our subjective
experience and the whole point of
science is to is to probe reality
reducing our subjective interpretation
by as much as is humanly possible
ideally to zero
yeah well refining the subjective model
so that it better and better predicts
the objective reality even though we'll
never be the objective reality it's a
highly effective predictive you know
apparatus this is Startalk
[Music]